Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Savenda Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, in Ordnung.
So heißt, ich werde ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Jakob. Jakob Mais.
Ja.
Wie heißt Ihr Name?
Jakob, J-A-K-O-B.
Mais, M-A-I-S.
I-S?
Ja.
Ohne E? Noa-S? Okay.
Noa-I-S ja. A-I-S.
Okay. Herr Mais, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 55, Frau Doktor.
55, okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
18, 1970.
18, okay. 1970.
Vielen Dank für den Geburtstag, Herr Mais.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor, aber ich fühle mich nicht gut. Deswegen konnte ich meinen Geburtstag nicht feiern. Ich konnte nicht gut Luft kriegen und ich hatte Schmerzen.
Schmerzen? In der Brust?
Ja, leider.
Seit wann haben Sie die Geburtstag?
Seit vier Tagen habe ich die Geburtstag.
Und es geht schlimmer. Es ist schlimmer geworden.
Ja, es ist sehr leid zu hören. Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Hinter?
Hinter ganz Brust, ich kann sagen.
Ganz Brust, okay.
Vor zehn Tagen hatte ich Erkältung.
Ich hatte Kräuter, Tee und Bonbons und so weiter. Ich habe viel eingenommen.
Ich fühlte mich besser, aber seit vier Tagen sind meine Schmerzen verschlimmert.
Ich habe Fieber, habe auch Hüsten und ich fühle mich nicht gut. Ich kann nicht laufen. Ich habe keine Kraft.
Okay, ja ich verstehe. Haben Sie beim Hüsten Ausruf auch?
Ja, ja, habe ich auch.
Wie ist Ihr Ausruf?
Grünlicher oder grünlicher Ausruf, kann ich sagen.
Grünlicher und grüner. Okay.
Und haben Sie seit vier Tagen Hüsten?
Ja, seit vier Tagen habe ich Hüsten.
Gestern Nacht konnte ich nicht schlafen. Ich hatte gezittert und aufgewacht.
Ich habe meine Kleidung wechselt.
Dann schwitze ich, wie ich geduscht habe.
Ich habe ein Kaltwassertemperatur gemessen. Es war 39,5 Grad.
Ich habe ein Paracetamol genommen. Meine Fieber hat gesunken. Heute Morgen habe ich auch Fieber.
Heute Morgen ist meine Fieber 40 Grad. Ich fühle mich total schlafen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Und haben Sie auch Atemnot?
Ja, ich kann nicht Blut bekommen.
Im Ruhe auch? Haben Sie Atemnot?
Besonders wenn ich auf der Treppe steige, aber im Ruhe auch. Seit heute Morgen habe ich Atemnot.
Okay. Aber haben Sie vor vier Tagen keine ähnlichen Beschwerden?
Vor zehn Tagen hatte ich Erkältung. Ich habe Schnupfen.
Seit vier Tagen habe ich Hüsten und Brustschmerzen.
Ich habe ein komisches Gefühl, ein enges Gefühl. Ich weiß nicht, aber das stört mich sehr.
Haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen?
Brustschmerzen, ja.
Ja, ich habe Kodion und ein acetyl-System angenommen wegen Hüsten und Auswurf.
Aber das hat mir nicht geholfen. Ich habe eine Linderung gebracht.
Okay. Haben Sie diese Medikamente in die Hausarzt verschieben?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten hat mein Hausarzt diese Medikamente geschrieben und ich hatte eine Pause. Deswegen habe ich selbst eingeladen.
Okay. Haben Sie vor sechs Monaten eine Erkältung gehabt?
Ja, einmal hatte ich Hüsten. Vor sechs Monaten. Aber es dauerte drei Tage. Dann war ich gesund.
Okay. Ich verstehe. Wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Meis?
Ja, ich bin 69, Frau Doktor.
Okay. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 78.
78. Okay. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Herr Wagner.
Okay. Danke schön für diese Informationen.
Und haben Sie im Blut in Ihrer Hüsten oder in Ihrer Auswurf bemerkt? Blut?
Blut habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Es freut mich. Und schlafen Sie gut? Nein. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit zwei Tagen kann ich nichts gut essen. Ich esse nur Suppe.
Okay. Und in letzter Zeit haben Sie ungewöhnlich ab oder so genommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Sehr gut. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Seit gestern pinkle ich sehr wenig. Aber Stuhlgang ist ganz normal.
Trinken Sie ausreichende Getränke? Denken Sie?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, Frau Doktor. Aber ich habe Fieber und gesittert.
Ja. Ich trinke aber ich weiß nicht ob es ausreichend ist.
Okay. Herr Meis, sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, ich leide an seit sieben Jahren Bluthochdruck. Und hatte auch vor drei Jahren Forschter der Lüse Parsinom.
Parsinom? Oh.
Ja, vor drei Jahren. Und wurde es mit Bestrahlung behandelt.
Okay. Sind Sie jetzt gesund? Oder sind Sie...
Ja, ich fühle mich gerückt. Aber ich nehme regelmäßig ein Medikament.
Gocerelin. 3 mg monatlich unter Hautimplantat.
Implant. Okay. Könnten Sie wiederholen der Name des Medikaments?
Gocerelin. 3 mg monatlich.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und nehme ich auch ein Norvax Tablett. Norvax 10 mg Tablett. Ich nehme regelmäßig.
Ja, morgens?
Noch etwas? Haben Sie einige Medikamente? Nein? Okay. Sehr gut.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Meis?
Ja, wegen Orchester Lüse Parsinom wurde ich operiert. Danach habe ich Bestrahlung gehabt.
Vor drei Jahren, okay. Noch etwas? Nein, habe ich keine mehr.
Okay. Rachen Sie, Herr Meis?
Ja, ich raufe gerne 10 Zigaretten pro Tag. Seit wann rauen Sie?
Seit 30 Jahren. Meine Ökologie hat mir empfohlen aufzuhören, aber ich könnte es nicht schaffen.
Deswegen rauche ich.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, aber wir müssen diesen Subjekt wiederholen. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke manchmal Bier. Ein oder zwei Bier.
Ein oder zwei Flaschen Bier. Manchmal am Monat oder ein bis zwei Mal.
Ja, einmal pro Woche oder dreimal pro Monat.
Okay. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, niemals.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich laufe zweimal pro Woche. Ich laufe gerne.
Okay. Sehr gut. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater oder meine Mutter?
Ja, leider ist mein Vater an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Und meine Mutter hat leider eine Zuckerkrankheit und Bluthochdruck.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder. Er ist gesund, denke ich.
Er war gesund gestern.
Okay, ich verstehe. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Okay, sehr gut. Und leben Sie alleine oder mit jemandem zusammen?
Ich habe eine Familie, Frau Doktor.
Sie sind verheiratet. Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Töchter.
Sehr gut. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, meine kleine Tochter ist leider an Asthma.
Asthma. Okay.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Ja, ich habe Nussallergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, mit Halskratzen und Jücken reagiere ich.
Halskratzen. Okay. Okay.
Okay, Sie verstehen die Gift?
Ja, denke ich.
Okay. Waren Sie in Lesse seit... im Ausland?
Im Ausland, im Lestejahr waren wir meines Inseln mit meiner Familie.
Aber in Lesse.
Okay.
Waren Sie in Lesse in der Umgebung mit den Beschwerden?
Ja, in Lesse war ein Kollege im Ausland.
Viele Kollegen waren erkeunt.
Und nach der Erkältung hatte ich einige Beschwerden wie meine Kollegen.
Okay. Haben Sie Impfung gegen Pneumokok oder Grippe?
Was ist Pneumokok, Frau Doktor? Was ist Pneumokok? Weiß ich nicht.
Pneumokok ist eine Bakterien-Lungenentzündung verursacht.
Aber das ist eine der Namen eine Impfung, Pneumokok-Impfung.
Okay. Ich habe keine Pneumokok-Impfung gehabt, aber ich bin geimpft gegen Covid-19 viermal.
Kinder und Krankheiten, ich bin geimpft.
Und Tetanus und Grippe.
Okay. Haben Sie einen Covid-Test gemacht?
Covid-Test? Warum, Frau Doktor?
Sie haben eine Lungenentzündung. Ich glaube, das ist eine Halsentzündung.
Wie viele Mal können Sie einen Covid-Test machen?
Nein, ich habe keinen Covid-Test gemacht.
Oder haben Sie in Hausarzt einen Covid-Test gemacht? Nein.
Nein, nein, nein. Aber das ist gefährlich, Yavuz.
Kann ich zu Hause gehen? Ist das, wenn ich Covid habe?
Jetzt ist es zu früh, etwas zu Genres zu sagen.
Aber ich denke, sie muss ein paar Stunden im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Nach der Untersuchung entscheiden wir, ob sie im Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Aber ich möchte diese Informationen jetzt sagen.
Und habe ich keine weiteren Fragen, Herr Meis? Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen?
Mein Vater ist eine Lungenkrebsgestörung. Deswegen habe ich Angst.
Kann ich eine Lungenkrebs-Störung haben, Frau Doktor?
Herr Meis, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge sehr gut.
Aber bitte denken Sie nicht gleich an das Schlimmste.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich einige Untersuchungen durchführen muss, auch um die Krebs auszuschließen.
Aber zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Und einige Laborparameter überprüfen.
Und danach eine weitere Untersuchung durchführen.
Und ich werde sie mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen etwas Genres sagen.
Aber zuerst werde ich Ihnen Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ihre Sauerstoffsetzung, Atemfrequenz und Herzfrequenz und Ihren Blutdruck und Puls.
Dann werde ich Sie eine Zugatt legen und eine Fiebersenkung verabreichen.
Dann werden wir alle Ergebnisse beurteilen und ich werde Ihnen etwas Genres sagen.
Frau Doktor, können Sie einen Covid-Test durchführen?
Ja, ich kann. Aber zuerst möchte ich eine Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen und die Bluttest-Ergebnisse sehen.
Dann werden wir eine Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen.
Wie wird ein Covid-Test durchgeführt?
Wie wird? Gibt es Schnelltestpräparate?
Ja, das ist ein Testpräparat.
Dann werden wir eine Labortest überprüfen.
Okay, dann warten Sie.
Dann warten Sie in diesem Raum.
Eine Schwester wird Sie umkümmern.
Vielen Dank Frau Doktor, Sie sind sehr nett.
Okay, Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Der Patient heißt Jakub Mais, ist 55 Jahre alt, ein Mitte 78 groß und wiegt 69 Kilo.
Herr Mais stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen bestehender Zunehmender
Fieber mit heute Morgen 40 Grad,
mit grünlich und gelblich Auswurf und belastungabhängig Dyspina vor.
Der Patient klagt über auch Mielgier, Müdigkeit und nächtliche Hyperhydros, Schutafros und Zittern.
Die Einnahme Paracetamol, Anesthetik und Kodein haben den Patienten keine Besserung gebracht.
Der Patient berichtet, er hatte seit ca. 10 Tagen eine Erkaltung,
aber seit drei Tagen hat sich die Erkaltung verschlimmert.
In ihrem Arbeitsplatz haben viele Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen eine Erkaltung.
In der VEGATATIVEN Anamnese ist unaufhängig bis auf Schmerzbedingte, Insomni und inapathens.
Der Patient hat Oligo-Gri.
Er leidet seit 7 Jahren an arteriölig Pertoni.
Der Patient hat vor drei Jahren eine Prostate Carcino diagnostiziert.
Der Patient nimmt regelmäßig 10 mg Norvax morgens und er benutzt eine Implant Gocerelin 3,6 mg monatlich gegen Prostate Carcino.
Er ist Rache und er braucht seit 30 Jahren 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Er trinkt gelegentlich 1-2 Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Er braucht 2 Mal pro Woche.
Er arbeitet als Lehrer.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Tochter und seine kleine Tochter hat Asthma Bronchiale.
Er ist allergisch gegen Nuss mit den Symptomen von Halskratzen und Pyrurhitis.
Er ist verheiratet und seine Anamnesen sind unaufregend.
Die Anamnestischen haben die Anamnesen auf Pneumonie.
Die Asthma Bronchiale ist eine Asthma Bronchiale.
Sie ist in Betracht von COPD.
Das ist eine wichtige Information der Familienanamnese bei diesen Patienten.
Sein Vater ist an Bronchiale gestorben.
Seine Mutter leidet an Arteriellaepartonie und Diabetes mellitus.
Er hat einen gesunden Bruder.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Pneumonie?
Der Patient hat vor 3 Tagen Erkaltungssymptome.
Seit 3 Tagen hat er Höchstfieber, Thysiös, Dyspnoe und gründlich-gärtliche Ausrufe.
Die Symptome sprechen für eine Pneumonie.
Wie können wir sagen als Fachbegriff für Husten mit Auswurf?
Die Anamnese ist produktiv.
Um die Diabetes zu erklären, sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
So würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich würde alle vitalen Parameter kontrollieren.
Und gegebenenfalls eine Sauerstoffsetzung und ausreichende Flüssigkeit geben.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf Atemfrequenz, Herzfrequenz, Blutdruck und die anderen vitalen Parameter.
Ich auskultiere Lungen und Herz, um die Diagnose zu bestätigen und andere Patologien auszuschließen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Auskultation?
Bei der Auskultation erwarte ich eine pathologische Rungengeräusche als Gizem.
Wie sagen wir das?
Ihre Verdacht Diagnose ist eine Pneumonie.
Ich erwarte Rasselgeräusche und feuchte Rasselgeräusche.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das richtig ist.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das?
Ich weiß nicht.
Was ist das denn?
Was ist das?
Kennen Sie?
Nein, in der Türkisch.
Ok, also bei der Palpation.
Bei der Palpation können wir...
Ja, ich weiß.
Bei der Palpation, ich sage der Patient bitte sagen 99.
Dann ich palpiere die Lungen und ich fühle eine Geräusche oder eine Bewegung.
Also verminderte ist die Prämie.
Verstand es?
Ja, ich bin prämie.
Und ich würde den Patienten eine Rundkenaufnahme des Thorax in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Und meine Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich erwarte...
Ich erwarte den gleichen Bereich.
Also Fachbegriff, also Infiltration.
Ja, ja Infiltration.
Ob es das ist, ja Infiltration.
Ich erwarte betroffenen Lungenlappen Infiltration.
Und gegebenenfalls ein CT.
Ist sinnvoll.
Und ich würde Blut abnehmen.
Und ein großes Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter BSG und CRP.
Und Nieren und Lebewerte bestimmen lassen.
Und einen Covid-Test.
Und ich würde einen Covid-Test durchführen um die Covid auszuschließen.
Dann Prokastonin.
Bronchiakastonin.
Nein, das ist spezifisch bei der Pneumonie.
Ja, Prokastonin.
Und ich würde im Blut Prokastonin überprüfen.
Prokastonin.
Ja.
Okay.
Wurde schon die körperliche Untersuchung durchgeführt.
Und dann Labouruntersuchungen auch dann?
Labouruntersuchung und Röntgen und CT veranlassen.
Dann sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen.
Schlage ich die Volgandentherapie vor.
Wie?
Ja.
Würden Sie diesen Patienten stationär oder ambulant behandeln?
Nein, nein.
Ich würde den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Um die Stabilisierung der Patienten zu stabilisieren.
Er hat 40 Grad Fieber.
Er hat Atemnot und Zunämen der Thursis.
Deshalb denke ich, den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Können Sie KURB 65 Plasifikation?
Wiederholen.
KURB 65.
Kennen Sie?
Nein.
KURB 65.
Okay. Machen Sie weiter.
KURB 65. Nein, ich weiß nicht.
Ich würde eine Zugang legen.
Ich würde eine Fieber senken.
Ich würde eine Fieber ausreißen.
Ich würde eine Antibioterapie beginnen.
They get heute.
Ich empfehle den Patienten Nikotin und Alkoholkarant wartens.
Auch natürlich ...
überwache den Patienten engmischig. Ja. Okay. Also Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie gegebenenfalls
eine Bronchoscopie durchführen würden. Könnten Sie bitte Bronchoscopie erklären? Ja. Bronchoscopie
ist eine Lungenspiegelung. Ich meine, mit Hilfe der Bronchoscopie können wir die Atemweg und
Lungen beurteilen. Vor dieser Untersuchung sollte sich die Patientin acht Stunden noch
da sein. Und vor dieser Untersuchung können wir eine örtliche Betäubung, eine Spray im Magen,
aber falls die Patientin will, können wir eine Sedative verabreichen. Ja, ich glaube. Während wir
eine flexible Schlange in den Mund bis in die Lunge führen, mit einer Kamera. Diese Untersuchung
zeigt uns die Strukturen und die Pathologien in Atemweg und Lunge. Nach der Untersuchung
und gegebenenfalls können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen. Nach der Untersuchung sollte sich die
Patientin eine Begleitperson mitbringen, weil die Patientin eine Person mitbringt, um sie zu Hause zu bringen.
Nach der Untersuchung sollte die Patientin nicht autofahren oder die wichtigsten Dokumente
unterschreiben. Nach der Untersuchung darf der Patient nicht autofahren und die wichtigsten
Verträge unterschreiben. Okay, gut. Ich glaube, das ist genug. Bronchialawax ist eine
Wache Methode. Ja, ich glaube. Lungen spülen, Lungen spülen. Ja, Wache ist sehr gut.
Ich glaube, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ich glaube, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ich glaube, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Ich werde euch noch mal was zu Essen machen, aber ich weiß nicht, wie.
Vielleicht ist es zu viel. Aber Yavuz hat es verdient.
Wir nehmen euch die, die ihr nehmt, zu Essen. Oder wir sind zu Besuch.
Ich glaube, die erste Partie war sehr gut. Sie sagen, dass die erste Partie sehr wichtig ist. Ich hoffe, dass es gut wird.
Ich bin bereit.
Ja, bitte.
Die Vorerkrankungen leiden seit 7 Jahren an arteriöle Hypertonie. Dagegen nimmt ein Norwask 10 mg ein.
Darüber hinaus hat er vor 3 Jahren Prostatecarcinom mit Operation und Radiothegaphy behandelt.
Dagegen nimmt er 2,3,6 mg Coserillin. Er hat eine Allergie gegen Nuss, die sich mit Pyruritus und Hasskratzen äußert.
Er raucht seit 30 Jahren eine halbe Schachtel Zigaretten täglich. Er trinkt 1-2 Bier pro Woche. Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist verheiratet. Er hat 3 Töchter. Eine Töchter leidet an Asthma-Bronchiale. In der Familienanamnese fand sich bei der Mutter Diabetes mellitus und arteriöle Hypertonie.
Der Vater ist an Bronchialkalcinom verstorben. Er hat einen gesunden Bruder. Er ist vollständig geimpft. Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdacht Diagnose lautet auf Pneumonie. Dafür schiebt sich die Osten mit gelbischem und grünlichem Ausdruck, Fieber, Brustzimesen.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kommt an Asthma-Bronchiale, Myokarditis und in Betracht.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen. Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zuerst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Besonders in diesem Fall ist Sauerstoffsätigung, Fieber, Temperatur, Atemfrequenz und Blutdruck entscheidend.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren. Dabei würde ich den Allgemeinen Zustand des Patienten, Atemfrequenz beachten.
In diesem Fall ist die Inspektion wegweisend. Bei der Inspektion erwarte ich eine höhte Lungengeräusche.
Danach palpiere ich den Patienten. Dabei würde ich eine erhöhte Schittenpyramidus erwarten.
Zur weiteren Diagnostik würde ich eine Laborkuntersuchung durchschauen, um das Blutbild, Entzündungswerte, unter anderem CRP, ESG und Troponin, um eine Myokartenfarktus oder eine akute Koronärherzkrankheit auszuschließen.
Ich würde die Ergebnisse nicht direkt stationär aufnehmen. Zuerst muss ich die Ergebnisse warten.
Wir haben eine Schema. Das heißt, Kurb 65. C bedeutet Konfusion. R bedeutet Atemfrequenz.
Wenn über 30, das ist ein Punkt. Wenn Konfusion positiv ist, das ist auch ein Punkt. Dann Blutdruck.
Wenn systologe Blutdruck unter 90, das ist auch ein Punkt. Wenn der Patient mehr als 65 Jahre alt, das ist auch ein Punkt.
Wenn der Patient zwei Punkte hat, sollen wir stationär aufnehmen. Zuerst würde ich einen Venözugang ablegen, um eine Venöztherapie zu ermöglichen.
Als medikamentöse Therapie würde ich Antibiotikum verabreichen und Fluidzidzupf verabreichen. Das war alles.
Was empfehlen Sie nach der Behandlung des Patienten?
Atembewegung? Was meinen Sie damit?
Atembewegung? Nein. Rehabilitation. Atmenrehabilitation. Und fiel was hat Rican.
Und regelmäßige Impfung gegen Pneumokok, gegen Influenza.
Wie können wir bei der CT-Destorax eine Pneumonie diagnostizieren?
Bei Pneumonie können wir Infiltration sehen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Spirometrie durchführen?
Spirometrie ist in der Regel im Asthma-Bugunschale und COPD entscheidend. Ich empfehle nichts in diesem Fall.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Atembewegung durchführen?
Soeben würde ich nicht empfehlen.
Was würden Sie erhöhte Fieber senken?
Wie würde ich?
Ich habe schon einen Venouszugang abgelegt. Ich gebe den Patienten Paracetamol.
Um Fieber zu senken. Und wir können auch Metrimazol geben.
Oder wir können Ibuprofen Tabletten verabreichen.
Gibt es Intravenous Paracetamol präparat?
Perfalkan. Das heisst Perfalkan.
Wie können wir eine Tyberklose ausschließen?
Wir können PPD-Hauttest machen.
Und?
Und wir können im Röntgen-Torax erkennen.
Wie können wir eine Covid-19 ausschließen?
Wir können Covid-Schnelltest durchführen.
Mit Auswurf entnehmen.
Ich habe die Paracetamol-Propagung vergessen.
Die Trophen.
Trophen und Abschiebungen.
Nasen-Abschiebungen oder Orale-Abschiebungen.
Nasen-Orale-Abschiebungen.
Wenn der Patient selbst machen möchte, Orale-Abschiebungen machen.
Wenn wir in Kramkenhaus Covid-19-Test machen,
dann machen wir einen Abschiebungs-Test.
Und dann machen wir die Info.
Okay.
Wie können wir eine Broseal-Karzinom ausschließen?
Zuerst würde ich eine CT-Ferranlase machen.
Wenn ich eine Befunde sehe, sollte ich eine Nadel-Biopsi veranlassen.
Oder durchführen.
Oder wir können mit Bronchoskopie ausschließen.
Oder bestätigen.
Okay.
Ich habe alle Fragen gestellt.
Danke.
Herr Obener.
Ich möchte einen neuen Patienten aufnehmen.
Ich würde den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Es handelt sich um Jakob Meis.
Herr Meis ist 55 Jahre alt.
Er ist 69 Kilogramm schwer.
Und er ist 1,78 Meter groß.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen
seit fünf Tagen bestehenden Produktivierungen vor.
Der Patient stellt sich vor,
dass er vor fünf Tagen eine Erkautung oder Influenza
hatte.
Zunächst erwähnt er den Patienten,
dass er eine Influenza hatte.
Die Einnahme von Paracetamol,
Acetyl-System und Kodein hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Symptome sind mit Dyspno, Tramo,
Trichomonas,
und der Erkundung.
Die Symptome sind mit Dyspno, Tramo,
Trichomonas,
und der Erkundung.
Die Symptome sind mit Dyspno, Tramo,
Trichomonas,
Hyperhydrosis und nach Schweiß einher.
Die Frage nach Gewichtverlust wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufwendig
bis auf Inapetens, Insomni und wenige Urin.
An der Erkautung
sind die Arteriellehypertone
in der Bechsteinung
und die Prostata-Karcinome.
Diese Probleme
sind mit den Patienten
die Prostektome entstanden.
Die Prostektome entstanden.
Danach wurden diese Probleme
mit der Schüttertherapie behandelt.
Er nimmt
Gesorethin, vielleicht.
Gesorethin, 3,6 mg Tablet Monatlich
und Norvaksenmiligramm morgens ein.
Der Patient reagiert allergisch auf Mus,
die äußert sich mit Hasskrassen.
Er raucht 10 Zigaretten seit 20 Jahren.
Und er trinkt 1-2 Flaschen Bier gelegentlich.
Der Anamnese
ist mit dem Vater
an der Pulmonarkarcinome verstorben.
Die Mutter hat Leiden an Diabetes Melitus
und Arteriellehypertone.
Er hat einen Bruder, der gesund ist.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Der Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Er tritt regelmäßig Sport.
Er läuft gerne.
Er ist Lehrer und verheiratet.
Der Patient hat zwei, drei Töchter.
Seine kleine Töchter leiden asthma.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Phenomone aus.
Da der Patient dafür typische Symptome aufweist,
ist der Patient mit Leiden und Dispneus,
Dispneus, Schuputum,
Thorax, Schmerzen, Fieber,
diese Symptome
sprechen für Phenomone.
Als Differenzierdiagnose kommen
Pulmonarkarcinome und Myokarditis
und Covid-19 in Betracht.
In meiner Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich zunächst den Patienten
eine Vita-Parameter überwachen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten
eine Körperliche Unterzuchtung
bei der Körperliche Unterzuchtung
auf der anderen Seite
bei Inspektion,
Tachibnü, Lippen, Zyanose,
Nasen, Flügel, Atmung gibt
und bei Palpation
gibt es Schittemfremitus,
Versteckte Schittemfremitus gibt.
Danach würde ich den Patienten auskültern.
Bei der Auskülterin
achte ich darauf, ob
feinblasige Rasengeräusche
und abgeschwacktes Atemgeräusch vorliegen.
Neben Körperliche Unterzuchtung
wären Labarunterzuchtungen
sinnvoll, um umfassende
Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich
Blutblut, CRP, BSG,
Enzyme
bestimmen lassen.
Außerdem würde ich eine
Sputumkultur und
eine Ersatzprobleme auskültern.
Zunächst würde ich eine
Röntgen-Torax-Durchführung
um meine Verdachtung
um so meine Verkörung
zu machen,
um die Ersatzprobleme
zu verhindern.
Außerdem würde ich
eine
Gegebenenfalt
durch die
Ersatzprobleme
auskültern.
Außerdem würde ich
eine
Gegebenenfalt durch
die Ersatzprobleme
auskültern.
Um die mögliche andere
Lungenprobleme
auszulüsten.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtdiagnose
bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten
stationäre aufnehmen.
Zunächst würde ich den Patienten
eine Phylosophore
verabreichen.
Dann würde ich eine
Pulmonarkonzil anordnen.
Dann würde ich die
Ersatzprobleme
auskültern.
Dann würde ich die
Ersatzprobleme
auskültern.
Dann würde ich die Ersatzprobleme
geplanten Untersuchungen fortsetzen, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, was empfehlen Sie während der Therapie den Patienten?
Ja, ich empfehle zuerst den Flüssigkeitssuffo, danach Antibiotikum.
Außerdem empfehle ich den Patienten Antitussiv und Mykolitikum und Antipiratikum.
Herr Oberarzt, aber gegebenenfalls würde ich den Patienten Saustoffe geben.
Okay, wie können wir ein Bronchialcarcinom ausschließen?
Mit der Anamnesse gab es keine gewissen Verluste und Nachschweiß.
Aber um meine Bronchialcarcinome auszuschließen, würde ich den Patienten Thorax und MRT veranlassen.
Ja, Herr Oberarzt.
Würden Sie ein Bronchialcarcinom ausschließen, würden Sie eine Bronchoscopy durchführen?
Jetzt empfehle ich nicht den Patienten eine Bronchoscopy durchführen, weil bei einer starken Infektion eine Bronchoscopy nicht durchführt.
Nach der Akute Behandlung würde ich den Patienten eine Bronchoscopy entfalten.
Können wir mit Hilfe von Ultraschall-Desthorax eine Pneumonie diagnostizieren?
Ich habe keine Erfahrung über diese Thema, Herr Oberarzt.
Aber nach der Behandlung werde ich diesen Fall nachschlagen.
Okay, würden Sie in diesem Fall eine EKG schreiben und warum?
Ja, natürlich. Ich empfehle den Patienten eine EKG schreiben, weil der Patient Bruce Schmerzen hat.
Bruce Schmerzen hat ein Schilderbock.
Herr Kollegen, wie würden Sie eine Tuberkulose ausschließen?
Wenn Sie eine Tuberkulose ausschließen würden Sie eine PPD machen, aber eine PCR veranlassen.
Dann würde ich die PPD durchführen.
Gibt es andere Möglichkeiten, Herr Oberarzt?
Schöpfer Kultur.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Können wir Sie COVID-19 behandeln?
COVID-19 behandeln.
Zuerst den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und isolieren.
Dann werden die Patienten viele Medikamente veranlassen.
Aber jetzt habe ich keine Erfahrung über diese Thema, Herr Oberarzt.
Wir können zu Hause behandeln, Flüssigkeit suchen, viel Wasser trinken, Antipirätikum, Betruche empfehlen.
Es gibt keine bestimmte oder spezifische Therapie.
Danke schön für diese sehr besondere Informationen, Herr Oberarzt.
Können Sie uns EKG aufklären?
Ja, Herr Oberarzt. EKG ist eine spezielle Untersuchung, mit der wir elektrische Aktivitäten beurteilen können.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Erkrankungen, die Rhythmuskulschwecken,
Angina Pectoris, Herz, Hände, Myokard und Paktus frühzeitig zu erkennen.
Dazu setzen wir viele Elektroden auf Brust, den Arm und den Beinen ein.
Die Bilder des Herzens werden als Kurve auf einem Monitor dargestellt.
Die Untersuchung dauert ungefähr 5-10 Minuten.
Die Untersuchung ist ungefährlich und röntgenfrei und schmerzfrei.
Es gibt keine bestimmte Vorbereitung.
Es wird keine Nadel- und Kontrastmittel benötigt.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen.
Die Patientin kann ihre Erkrankungen wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Sie kann sich mit einer Ächokardiografie oder anderen Untersuchungen durchgeführt.
Aber das hängt von der Erkrankung.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollegen!